[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's the popular co-host of pro football
talk live with mike florio he's chris
sims who joins us on the program
chris did the interview in air quotes
with shannon sharp about with julio
jones help
or hurt the situation of trading him
it hurt i think more than anything i
don't think it hurt in a big way
now like listen i i mean i i think like
you i mean that that's not a good look i
don't like that shannon sharp did that
to julio jones and you know i said on
the show yesterday on pft that
from from the sources i know connected
the situation yeah that julio jones and
his agent were ticked off about that and
all of those things but
at the same time i don't think it really
hurts
the leverage of the trade really
ultimately
because listen we all know he's been on
the trade market
they've been having conversations with
teams it's not like these teams saw that
interview and went oh
it's official he's being traded guys now
we can work this against him we got the
leverage we know he wants out of there
i don't as long as there's more than one
team involved i don't think it affects
it
a whole lot except it's maybe
made it more of a known thing that
julio wants out there out of there maybe
more than the other way around
but also with matthew stafford you know
the lions just said we're open for
business
and i wondered if it was going to hurt
their leverage and they got a great
offer there
exactly that's why i think it's
overblown i'm kind of with you i don't
think it really matters either way
julio's really good
as long as teams start to get
comfortable with where he's at
physically
you know i think there will be a bidding
war i would not be shocked to see the
titans and the colts and
the patriots really trying to get his
services i do think there's still a lot
of special play left in julio jones body
okay where do you think he wants to go
i think the two at the and this is
another thing i said on on the show
earlier this week with
you know really same person that kind of
let me know about you know the
uh unhappiness of the shannon sharp
interview
is that the titans and the patriots are
two of the teams that are
on the top of his radar for sure they
make sense to me
certainly i mean both teams you know
really good
he can be a definitely a big time
missing part as far as an explosive
like one big play type of guy for that
new england patriots offense
the titans have that in aj brown but we
know they like to play two tight ends
smash mouth football only have two
receivers on the field a lot of times
and they lost corey davis in free
agencies so i think that's one that
jumps out to me and if i'm him too
i'll say this team that i would be the
colts would be it the colts to me are
fringe you know and i know we need to
see carson wentz but the rest of the
roster is
they're a fringe super bowl window type
team right now too
who does not have that big time
difference maker at wide receiver
can you imagine if carson wentz is good
this year
or really good like i think he's going
to i i think
you know he's with frank reich he's got
protection he's got a good offensive
line
and you're right you get julio jones you
had another weapon
for him and uh carson wins could make a
lot of people look bad
if he plays well with the colts i i'm
i'm
more with you too like if you made me
bet money on how carson once does this
year i'm
i would bet on it's going to be good to
really good
you know i know last year was a disaster
but you and i discussed during the year
last year i mean
everything was a disaster there the
offense the pass protection no
run game no good receiver to get open
none of that lend itself to like great
quarterback play and then of course he
compounded it and made it worse but
you know i think the point is let's not
forget though the year before that he
carried
a team on his back and got them to the
playoffs when he got hurt against the
seahawks and all that
and we've seen other inklings in history
too like the year he tore his acl when
he was on
you know an mvp type pace to know that
it is in him
if the support's around him and that's
why i'm like you i think it's going to
be a good year for carson wentz
anything change in green bay in your
opinion after the interview on espn with
kenny ming
no i mean you know it's more cryptic
aaron rodgers
language and signals and things like
that but i think basically what he was
trying to say it's about the people
and all those type of things i mean my
take on that was he was going like
you know about the people about the
foundation foundation he feels
personally disrespected
as he's one of those important people
you know in the organization let alone
maybe the foundation for all their
success but chris help me understand
this
yeah aaron rodgers talks about the
legacy the tradition
the town the his teammates his
coaches why would you give up all of
that because of
one guy yeah who disrespected you and
didn't call you
the night they drafted a quarterback
right i'm
with you i wouldn't like abandon ship
for all those positive things you've
you've just mentioned
and i think ultimately rogers is smart
enough and legacy aware enough to that's
why i think he'll be
back there i think that's kind of why
he's been sending out these messages
through john [ __ ] and everybody else to
kind of be like
you know everything's good except for
these two jerks in the front office that
i don't like
you know and you're right i don't think
you sacrificed that
now maybe after this year okay where
there's no
you know actual commitment to him and
all those things
hey i understand that and i do
understand him being angry about how
that went down
and all the other reasons around it but
i i'm with you
i mean they're in a window he's really
good
he can still put up huge stats and they
were very close to getting to the super
bowl last year and i i don't think he'll
abandon that
but if you're the packers and you can
solve the problem
by trading for julio jones then you say
to aaron rodgers
hey we we hear you we we got julio jones
for you
yes i that this is something both florio
and i have been talking about on the
show
a lot the last few days like if you want
to mend that relationship
that would go a long way and you know
again like we talked about with some of
the other teams there
it just can't always be rogers being
perfect you know on a nine play drive
with
you know six high level completions and
and he had to dodge the rush a few times
to me that's the problem with the
packers that's why they can't get over
the hump
it's always about him being perfect
there's never like hey i can throw a
slant to this guy and he broke a tackle
and ran for 50 yards or
this guy just beat man-to-man coverage
and we blew by him and we threw a
60-yard bomb
they missed that and to me those are
very important elements
when you get to the playoffs because you
can't always expect to execute
10 and 12 play drives and be perfect and
beat the better defenses in football
he's chris sims from uh pro football
talk and i have a sneaky
mvp pick okay you want to guess
um uh uh carson wentz probably would
have been my guess
as far as a sneaky one um how about
matthew stafford maybe that
yep is that am i right yeah
damn see it's you know we're friends
we're friends we're simpatico
we're yeah we're in the trust tree
together co-workers
we're co-workers we're call working out
for friends you know but
oh okay fine the hell with you we're not
friends i'll meet you at the
dispensary how about that i'll meet you
at the time
it sounds good that's how i make my
friends i'll see you there
uh better chance to be mvp justin
herbert or matthew stafford
oh i'll go with stafford
i i got to see the chargers new head
coach
new offensive coordinator you know young
quarterback in the second system
i i have more faith than the fact that
stafford could learn
you know a system that i don't think is
overly complex
and be thrust into a team that's really
damn good already
and he can make it better and i think
you know the wins and losses and all
that
could add up to yes stafford mcvay i'm
very excited to see how that all works
out
i ordered my tim tebow jersey but i was
informed that i will not receive it
until july
7th july 7th yes
back order uh no i think they want to
maybe maybe the roster and that his
number becomes official then
but uh should i have bought a tim tebow
jags jersey chris
no no you should not have i i could tell
you that that was a waste of money that
you could have gave to me and i could
have spent to other places
yes at the dispensary at the dispensary
right okay
so it worked why did urban meyer feel
the need to do this
because of this undying loyalty he has
to a player that he looks at
as a special player in person
but i mean i think it is risky for
for i'm sure a lot of the reasons you've
talked about and everything like that
yeah
he's going to get the side eye urban
meyer and tim tebow alike
and they're going to see how he's
treated in those issues but yet to me
it opens up a can of worms more than the
you know positives i think that you can
get out of this situation but if you
were
on the jags and you're a veteran right
and would you
and and being a quarterback would you
have any
like would you have an issue with this
and and what would you do
i'd be thinking about it a little bit
like i can speak to experience of
tebow got to denver right after i i was
released by the denver broncos
i know that veterans in that locker room
were very annoyed that he made himself
available to the media every day even
though he was the second and third
string backup
that's the things that can bother the
veterans in the locker room
he made himself available how like he
was willing to sit there in front of the
media and take
questions and talk every day on a daily
basis
they put up that billboard right about
like bench
kyle orton let's play tim tebow you know
he never said like hey take that down
kyle orton's the starter all those
things i know that rubbed people wrong
in denver in that locker room and if he
does
that type of stuff yes he's going to be
he's not going to get a lot of respect
in the locker room the quarterbacks on
the other hand i mean
i mean come on we know trevor lawrence
he shouldn't be threatened but i'm sure
going through his head is he
like wait am i going to lead us on a
99-yard drive
and then we're going to get to the
one-yard line and we're going to give it
to tebow so he can
run it in the end zone and do that like
i wouldn't lie if i was trevor lawrence
that'd be going through my head right
now
but do you think tebow's viewed as a
self-promoter here
um i do yes i i do
think he is viewed as a self-promoter i
think players view him that way as well
yeah
and he was that way in denver he was
that way in denver i think people have
always thought he's that way to a degree
even here what he did in this this
circumstance
you know he caa him
they release it the night of the draft
about the jaguars information
come on that was self-promotion it just
got squashed because oh thy great one
aaron rodgers came out with bigger news
that night
that that squashed it but that that to
me
was part of the self-promotion to get
this ball rolling
start putting pressure on jacksonville
to do it get the fan base and the tebow
maniacs and all them in northern florida
to start clamoring for it i think that
was all a planned attack by tebow and
his camp
you are putting out your quarterback
list i am
is this the top 40 quarterbacks top 40
quarterbacks right now
right all things are equal everybody's
playing on the same team
i'm the head coach and it's basically
my pecking order of quarterbacks it's my
it's my depth chart
that's how i that's how i'm doing it
right now who's 40.
um case keenum was 40. okay that's
mcglovin's guy one of his guys
yep yeah mclovin is re when he falls for
a quarterback he really falls for a
quarterback
he's got uh he loves andy dalton too is
andy dalton in the
30s he's he's coming up he's
not we haven't hit him yet but he won't
be too long so don't worry and you know
how can you have a name like mclovin and
not fall in love with people i mean it's
just i i would expect that yes well i
did the first
you know quarterback crush was this
lefty kid out of texas back in the day
that's right that's right it was a wise
move very wise
cole mccoy is right-handed oh yeah
you're funny you're funny you're both
jerks and you're funny
uh are you going to so you already know
you're top 40 right
oh yeah i got it all down yep okay
definitely that's all i tinkered with
all week last week
i stressed out about it like i go to
dinner on with the wife on friday night
and she's like what are you thinking
about i'm like
oh i'm sorry the my list i'm always
thinking so
uh it overtakes my life here for a
period of time okay is there somebody
i know that you're going to create some
headlines here you always do
but is there somebody who's going to be
viewed as being too high on the list
or somebody who's going to be viewed as
too low on the list which which one
brings the controversy here
i i you know when i look at it i think
there's like
you know and i really i'm going by like
my producers and people there's about
three or four
people at different spots that i think
could cause
yeah a stir a crazy because they don't
see it the way i do or whatever else
listen
one's already happened i made justin
fields 39 and
i'm getting eviscerated on you know
social media
so that's just you know part of the game
it's the same thing
last year i made two of 40. i got the
same type of reaction and those type of
things it's not disrespect to any of
these guys
i hope justin fields proves me wrong
it's just where he's at right now he's
unproven he hasn't played
and i had questions about him coming out
in the draft so um but yes you know me
uh not that i try to do this but maybe
my beliefs and studies are just
different than others
i'm gonna have a few that i think are
gonna but you have keller in the pot
helen monde ahead of justin fields
i do i had kellen monde in front of
justin fields and trey lance throughout
the draft process to me
kellen mon i'm i'm putting the
proclamation out here that he's going to
be the dak prescott of this draft like
the guy that went to the fourth round
everybody nitpicked him because of team
reasons
and he fell and that i i just i look at
kellen mann
really you could argue that mac jones
and kellen monde were the two most
pocket ready quarterbacks not saying
they're the best dan
but playing from the pocket that is
where monde was special to me
an nfl ready special to me where pocket
collapsing doesn't need space has a big
arm
really goes through reeds the right way
can throw into tight windows
and that's nfl football when it's all
said and done
if you're kirk cousins yeah should you
be nervous
not right now i don't think so but
i do think monde is the type of talent
uh that cousins is gonna feel his
presence throughout the year even though
he's the starter because
he's the i think the kind of guy where
you know guys are gonna come off the
practice field and coaches every now and
then and go
whoa did you see some of those throws by
mon today wow
that was special did you see him take
off around the corner on that bootleg
and run 50 yards down the sideline
those type of things will get the hype
to where kirk cousins will feel the
pressure
maybe more about 2022 rather than right
now this moment
yeah i think it's interesting and and a
lot of the success and you know this
is the team you go to and a lot of times
you know when
like joe burrow if you put joe burrow on
kansas city
right like who knows what kind of
numbers but he's with cincinnati right
now
um i think that's what made what you
know herbert did with the chargers
you know a good team and injury played
team but still a better team
uh and and i i i think if you look at
success there are a lot of guys who
failed
and they failed because they went to a
bad organization
and they're guys who succeeded who
probably have succeeded because
they went later in the draft and got
with a better team a better organization
a better situation maybe they weren't
asked to start right away
exactly right you got a chance to
develop the pressure wasn't on them to
carry the team right from the get-go
you know like you're saying the support
system's there already
so it can accentuate the talents you
know i do i know you and i have
discussed this before but i think that's
one of the people
things people like dropped the ball on
with that you know the mahomes borough
conversation you're just talking about
hey mahomes i know any team he would
have gone to we would have saw the
talent
and gone whoa he does some really cool
special things i get that
but the fact that he got to go to a team
that had a good system
had a coach that really like you know
was all about the quarterback and really
like
lived lived it like he did through his
eyes
and then had the weapons that's when
yeah you get a jump off point to where
wait we have a great support system
around this guy and now it can really
accentuate
all his talents that he can bring to the
table so all the idiots in the world
even the
casual football viewers could go whoa
this guy's really damn good
and to me that's where a lot of teams
drop the ball on drafting quarterbacks
it's like the sam darnold new york jets
conversation
wait you draft a guy at number three you
make it the biggest thing in the
organization
and then you give them crap for three
years around them and then
you wonder why people are calling for
your head as a gm or going hey you guys
are stupid and all these and what a bad
pick at quarterback
you know you just can't do that at this
day and age it's inexcusable and you got
to give that guy support if you're going
to draft him high
thank you chris good luck with the list
and uh we'll be uh
closely monitoring so we can rip you as
always thank you work mate thank you
see you work mates bye-bye see at the
dispensary that's uh
chris sims co-host of pro football talk
live